why can't sharkboy breathe underwater
and why would supposedly valiant heroes
steal cookies here are a few things
about the adventures of sharkboy and
lava girl that people only seem to think
about once they've grown up in the mid
2000s robert rodriguez was arguably at
the height of his powers the texas-born
filmmaker had gone from producing el
mariachi for a mere seven thousand
dollars in 1992 to developing beloved
hits like desperado from dusk till dawn
and of course the spy kids films however
the adventures of sharkboy and lava girl
was undeniably a low point in the
director's career even the most inane
toilet humor-based kids movies will
often throw in some jokes for the
parents sharkboy and lava girl however
is aimed squarely at the kids and that's
because it was partially written by one
the opening titles of sharkboy and lava
girl introduce it as a rodriguez family
movie based on the dreams of
then-seven-year-old racer max rodriguez
who also played young sharkboy in the
opening scene the adults in the movie
although played by household name actors
like george lopez david arquette and
kristen davis still deliver stiff
awkward dialogue that sounds like a
child's idea of the way an adult might
speak for an adult hoping for action
like desperado a compelling narrative
like sin city or special effects like
elita battle angel sharkboy and lava
girl is certainly one of the less
compelling rodriguez films
the word dream or some variation of it
is uttered a total of 188 times
throughout sharkboy and lava girl's 93
minute run time that means the word is
being said on average once every 30
seconds but in some scenes it's much
more often than that even by the 50th
time it still isn't very clear what the
movie has to say about dreams other than
that they're a good thing to have young
max is mocked by his classmates for
reading stories about sharkboy and lava
girl from his dream journal but then his
dreams turn out to be real so linus and
the other kids learn that dreams are
good because they can become real but
max's dream almost destroys the school
and that doesn't sound very good at all
there's also the matter of max's parents
his father is an unemployed writer and
his inability to get a reliable job has
pushed his parents to the brink of
divorce at the film's climax rather than
finding some sort of mature compromise
the pair have a near-death discussion
where they remind each other that
they're best friends reconciling without
actually resolving the issue at hand
rather than have max's father figure out
a way to follow his dreams while still
supporting his family the movie just
ends sharkboy and lava girl make such a
repetitive point about the importance of
dreaming that it seems like it should
actually have something to say by the
end of it instead all this talk of
dreams eventually starts to sound more
like a nightmare
the adventures of sharkboy and lava girl
is on the one hand refreshingly colorful
and vivid during a time when even kid
targeted action movies were slowly
inching towards gloomy dystopian
franchises like the maze runner and the
hunger games the colorful world of
drools stood out as a unique vision on
the other hand when an adult watches
sharkboy and lava girl they see a film
drunk on its own green screen power one
that makes you wonder how it could have
possibly cost 50 million dollars to
produce at the time of the film's
release in 2005 cgi was being used more
and more in all sorts of movies but the
technology was at the end of an awkward
transitional phase sharkboy and lava
girl was shot almost entirely in front
of a green screen and it shows with its
more fantastical settings resembling a
window screensaver more than a major
motion picture that's not to say that
cgi heavy movies can't be good 1982's
tron and 2008 speed racer are both
underrated gems but as an adult watching
sharkboy and lava girl in 2021 it's hard
to not be distracted by visual effects
less sophisticated than an instagram
filter additionally the 3d technology
used for sharkboy and lava girl made for
a good selling point but did little to
actually make the film look good
sharkboy and lava girl utilized anaglyph
3d the kind that uses those red and blue
glasses which just made the movie look
even worse on the big screen as roger
ebert put it in his review fully three
quarters of the movie is in 3d which
looks more like 1d to me removing the
brightness and life of the movie's
colors and replacing them with a drab
listless palette which is about as
exciting as looking at a 3d bowl of
oatmeal
in 2005 george lopez was at the top of
his game he was gearing up for the fifth
season of his highly rated sitcom george
lopez he'd made cameos and shows like
curb your enthusiasm and he'd establish
himself as a well-respected stand-up
comedian in sharkboy and lava girl lopez
fully commits to his dual role as max's
teacher mr electricidad as well as one
of the chief bad guys on planet drool mr
electric both roles are over the top of
course and lopez mostly pulls them off
highlights include his demand for max
and his bully to be friends as a teacher
or his constant spouting of
electricity-based puns as a floating orb
with claws for hands
but why did george lopez also have to
provide a voice over from max's
childhood robot tobor following the
success of films like aladdin and shrek
hollywood had developed something of an
obsession with casting movie stars and
voice roles largely ignoring an entire
industry of talented voice professionals
who have been providing their talents to
cartoons and animated movies for decades
prior so rather than finding the perfect
voice actor to design an endearing
identity for tobo around the audience
gets george lopez again and yet again
for a fourth time as a guardian of the
ice princess robert rodriguez himself
even voices a talking shark further
trading creativity for mediocre
uninspired stunt casting
out of everyone in sharkboy and lavagirl
it's clear that future twilight
heartthrob taylor lautner is the actor
who possesses it that indefinable
quality that makes a movie star well a
movie star when production on the film
began lautner was just 12 years old he
already had an extensive martial arts
background earning a black belt by age 8
and appearing in a national karate
tournament in 2003. lautner was the
first and only actor to audition for the
role of sharkboy rodriguez was truly
convinced he was perfect from the very
beginning sure enough lautner sharkboy
is a glowering menace he never stops
moving in rages easily snarling and
yelling without holding back he plays an
important role in the most standout
action scene of the film using his
martial arts skills in an elaborate
fight with mr electric's dog-like cord
monsters rodriguez even asked lautner to
choreograph his own fight scenes lautner
also takes center stage for one of the
most bizarre and memorable moments of
shark boy and lava girl a ridiculous
inexplicably aggressive lullaby that he
sings to get max to fall asleep and
dream planet drool back to his rightful
shape he busts impressive dance moves
while sing yelling all sorts of absurd
lines it's a shame that taylor lautner
couldn't return for we can be heroes the
2020 quasi sequel to sharkboy and lava
girl as he was undoubtedly the true star
of the original
you'd think that the whole point of
having elements of max's dream world
echo elements of max's real world would
be to illuminate his relationships with
the people and things that surround him
lava girl for example asks max why he
made her shark boy's partner when
they're quote not compatible the same
words max's mother used to describe why
she and max's father are not getting
along such moments could if properly and
somewhat clearly presented give a film
like this greater depth unfortunately
sharkboy and lava girl breeze past the
questions as quickly as they bring it up
the additional presence of max's parents
as cookie hungry giants on planet drool
just serves to make things even more
confusing then there's mr electricidad
who allows his daughter marissa to face
off against a giant robot with his own
face on it while the idea of a girl
facing off against an imaginary
construct of her own father seems like
it could be richard symbolism such
moments don't seem to connect to any
greater theme other than revolving
around the loose freudian concept of
dreams being inherently meaningful
the adventures of sharkboy and lava girl
has a few off-putting attempts at the
sort of wink-wink adult humor of the
children's movies sometimes tackle with
wit and subtlety here however they come
across as awkward at best and just plain
confusing at worst at one point sharkboy
says he's heard that the ice princess is
the most beautiful girl on the planet
causing lava girl to get jealous and zap
him in the butt with her lava powers
other moments include mr electricity
dad's insistent that max stays away from
his daughter and linus's reaction to
lava girl burning his desk during
moments like these it feels like you can
see remnants of a screenplay with jokes
intended for adults but they're
ultimately more have baked than the
cookies in max's kitchen and we can be
heroes it is revealed that the pair
eventually got together and had a child
of their own at some point it seems that
what was once implied has now become
explicit it might seem like a minor
detail but early on in sharkboy and lava
girl max wakes up to find that the
cookies his mom baked and left in the
kitchen have been strangely consumed one
of the cookies has jagged shark-like
teeth marks in it while the other is
burnt and remains hot to the touch his
parents of course don't believe his
repeated insistence that it wasn't him
who ate the big treats and clearly
judging from the evidence it was
sharkboy and lava girl it's not until
the next day that the duo reveal
themselves as real heroes recruiting max
to help them save planet drool while
he's asleep in class as cute as the
scene might be it also begs a question
why bother sneaking into his house the
night before they were going to contact
him anyway are there heroes like santa
claus did they think it would be funny
to get max into trouble not only has max
seemingly discovered that sharkboy and
lava girl are real but in this scene he
also learns that they have no issues
with chocolate chip thievery
after he wraps up his battle with minus
on drool lava girl tells max to blink
three times which will take him home
much like dorothy clicking her heels
together in the wizard of oz when he
does so he wakes up back in his
classroom implying that a large portion
of what we've just seen was a dream of
some sort but during that dream max fell
asleep and had another dream inside of
that dream is that even possible it
seems like the adventures of sharkboy
and lava girl is a lot like inception
but without leonardo dicaprio patiently
explaining how things work there are
dreams within dreams and then those
dreams intrude on what you thought was
reality all along like dreams themselves
the whole thing is as impossible to
follow as it is to explain to anyone
else
this is yet another nitpick but it's the
sort of thing that can really nag an
adult up until the very last battle on
drool it is made abundantly clear that
sharkboy possesses the abilities of well
a shark after being lost at sea sharkboy
was raised by sharks growing sharp teeth
fins and gills as he adapted to the
shark lifestyle however in the big
showdown with mr electricidad electric
deals get the better of sharkboy nearly
causing him to drown you know because
sharks have to watch out or they could
drown
what about the gills that we saw all up
and down the sides at the beginning of
the film it's an example of a screenplay
giving a character a newfound limitation
simply because it is called for at that
particular moment to build dramatic
tension it's also frustratingly lazy
nearly two decades later the adventures
of sharkboy and lava girl continues to
hold a special place in the hearts of
those who discovered it as kids however
thanks to all sorts of bizarre moments
and choices you'd probably be doing
yourself a favor to keep the movie in
your memories rather than revisiting it
on your streaming side of choice
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one